it's exciting it's the first night of
Hanukkah tonight and you know what that
always man yes that's right you know
what it means it's time to attend a
taping of Conan O'Brien that it's
written actually in the Old Testament as
yes this is the best way to honor the
holiday we take we take one night's
material and stretch it out over many
nights we do that all throughout the
year yeah tonight is the first night of
Hanukkah this afternoon President Trump
marked the occasion by wishing the
Jewish people Merry Christmas
that's what he said Merry Christmas
finally you like that Merry Christmas
this morning President Trump made three
inaccurate statements in one tweet yes
or his Trump called that my personal
best that's what he said no he apology
he apologized said damn it I was going
for five inaccuracies this is crazy
scientists have found fossils from the
Ice Age in Los Angeles while they were
digging subway tunnels not crazy yeah la
residents were amazed and said we have a
subway
you gotta meet this guy
sir stand up
stand next to me
or your name is Sami
Summey and you're from I'm gonna guess
Finland yes this is the way all men
dress and stand in Finland he's mad but
may I borrow this for the rest of the
monologue do you mind is it okay I'll
give it back to you I just want to get
some of you
[Applause]
- look
yeah it's tell me some he's kind of like
a monochrome Where's Waldo yeah exactly
what I was going for big election
tonight in Alabama this is this is too
serious a topic you take this yeah yeah
you might want to thank you very much
sir and welcome to our country
you